Vale,
bueno, estamos en redes y vamos a hacer
redes locales y vamos a hacer un
simulacro de de examen y luego pasaremos
una
lo que sería un
un ejercicio de consolidación de de
conocimientos,
¿vale? Y lo vamos a corregir todo hoy
también. Vamos a, vale, en un primer
lugar, pues eso, o sea, si tenéis
packet, entiendo que todos tenéis packet
tras instalado y lo que vamos a hacer es
un ejercicio de en el que vamos a hacer
dos topologías de red, una red punto a
punto, podéis usar podéis usar
servidores, podéis usar los elementos
que queráis,
¿vale? Y por otro lado,
una red de eh
una red en tipo circular o tipo anillo,
¿vale? Y y lo mismo con al menos pues
que tenga
que tenga cinco cinco máquinas clientes
por lo menos,
¿vale? que y que y que sea operativa, o
sea, que tú puedas enviar enviar
paquetes de,
o sea, que no haya que no haya ahí,
vamos, que funcione, que esté operativa,
¿vale? Y os he dicho antes 15 minutos,
¿no? Os he dicho 20, tenemos 20 minutos
para hacerlo, ¿vale? Y lo enviáis por
aquí por el chat de Zoom.
Y luego os preparo el os preparo otro
ejercicio que este ya no sería de Packet
Tracer, sino de
A ver cuando lo cuando me lo entreguéis,
o sea, cuando lo enviéis por Zoom en
poner vuestro nombre en el en el nombre
del archivo.
Una pregunta, ¿alguno de los que de los
que estáis aquí necesitáis algún un
algún ordenador, o sea, todos tenéis
portátil, todos podéis venir con
portátil al examen,
¿eh? Yo no, yo no tengo portátil.
No tienes portátil. Tú puedes venir con
tu torre.
Y yo tampoco tengo portátil.
No tenéis portátil. Vale.
Eh,
a ver, yo lo que os dije en el en el
correo, o sea, si queréis paramos el
tiempo y y digo el ejercicio, lo que os
dije en el correo, si la torre no es muy
aparatosa, yo creo que es lo más, o sea,
tú llegas aquí con tu torre y la
Bueno, pero vosotros vosotros en el aula
11 sí que tenéis, ¿no? El ordenador.
Sí. Ver en la aula 11 que tenemos que
estamos nosotros por la mañana sí que
hay portátiles. Podemos pedir que nos
dejen uno,
o sea, el aula 11 aquí en el segundo
piso
o bueno, en el primer piso,
pero quiero decir torres, eh, una torre
sí que es vuestra, ¿no? Como como
alumnos de presencial.
Sí, sí.
Vale, vale. Es que a lo mejor
podemos hacer examen ahíes.
Claro, es que eso sería lo interesante.
Sí. estaría sería mucho más cómodo.
Es que eso por lo digo por eso, porque
tienes tu entorno, tu entorno de que
luego al final te deja un portátil, oye,
te tienes que instalar cosas de prisa y
corriendo y es que no es lo mismo, no es
tu entorno de trabajo ahí habitual.
Entonces, vale, yo lo hablo, ¿vale? Con
con en principio sí que
en principio sí que lo vamos a hacer en
el aula 11,
pero claro, igual cambia la película. Es
que es que ahí estaría el tema.
En principio se va a hacer ahí. No, no
hay no no creo que
que no lo hagamos ahí. Eso sí, me
tendréis que decir en qué sitio estáis
para que no se para que no se ponga otro
alumno, porque sí que vamos a estar
haciendo el examen junto con los de
Vale. Mi mi ordenador es el uno, el
primer ordenador,
el primero, el que está al lado del de
la mesa del profe,
¿no? No, el otro en plan el de que sale
profe es el cinco en plan el a
izquierda,
a la izquierda todo. Vale, vale, vale,
vale, vale. Bueno, o sea, a ver si se
nos sienta ahí alguien decimos, "Oye,
vete, vete de ahí. Esto es de
¿Qué es mío?" Ya está.
Es este al ese y ya está.
Claro.
Bueno, yo creo que en ese sentido sí que
lo vamos a solventar bien. Bueno, venga,
continuar con el con el ejercicio este.
No os molest en un rato.
Eh, era anillo y punto a punto.
Sí.
Vale.
Conforme vay teniéndolas, ir pasándolas
por aquí.
Se va cerrado y tengo que volver a
hacerlo todo.
Bueno, ostras, pues eso no le saben mal,
¿eh?
Eso por las prisas, Jorge.
Preferencias.
estuve.
Luego os diré para que para que no nos
pase lo que lo que te ha pasado, Jorge.
nos diré dónde encontrar
que nos haga un auto un auto backup de
de lo que estemos trabajando.
Y esta la versión nueve también.
Yo esta que tengo es la
la 8.2
van por la versión 9.
Ya está, ya te lo he pasado.
Vale, genial, genial. Gracias.
Falta Jorge ponerle
la IP a los
Sí, acabas de darme cuenta. Eh, hay que
ponerle de de
HCP.
No, no, tengo configurado arriba. Sí,
pero es que lo tengo puesto arriba.
Vale, vale. O sea, que has configurado
el servidor de HCP, pero luego no lo has
no lo has puesto, ¿no? En los
Es que como se me ha cerrado y en el
anterior lo tenía como que se me ha
olvidado y acabo de darme cuenta al
intentar mandar un paquete.
Vale, pero lo pones de de HCP y ya. A
ver. Hm. Claro, vigilar eso ya está.
Porque luego, claro, en el examamente es
una mala pasada estas cosas que una vez
has entregado
está ya más complicadillo,
pero bueno, eh,
a ver, por eso estamos de simulacross.
Lo has puesto en HCP los clientes. Lo
digo por por [__] esta.
Eh, ahora sí, si quieres te paso el
No, lo he cambiado, lo he cambiado yo.
No te no te lo he cambiado yo y ya está.
Si esto no es no es evaluable nada, o
sea, simplemente
es para que entrenéis
ahora el día de
claro, no es lo mismo
estar en dices, "Vale, tengo este
ejercicio que lo tengo que entregar en
en x días, tal,
a una situación en la que te tienes que
enfrentar 15, 20 minutos en el que en
los que tienes que hacer algo.
Entonces, por eso es interesante el tema
de de entrenarse, ¿no?
otra opción
a la hora de
hacer esta,
o sea, podemos poner de HCPO, ¿no?
Podemos ponerlo con hiperfijas.
Ya, pero como así solo configuro el
servidor y no tengo que ir poniendo una
a una, me parece mal.
Sí, claro, así era más fácil. Sí, pero
corres que se te vaya el santo al cielo
y no y te pase lo que te ha pasado.
Vale, mira, en el Espera, voy a esta la
voy a cerrar.
Bueno, voy a crear una
también una cosa a comentar de lo que te
he mandado,
que no sé por qué pasa, es del switch e
3 al cu
te aparece la
en el cable hay un circulito,
pero no he conseguido ni cambiando los
switches ni nada que se vaya el
circulito ese.
Debe ser una configuración de cantidad
de elementos. Si tú quitas un quitas un
switch y pones y pones un hard, deja de
tener el circulito.
Bueno,
o sea, mejor que ponga house, ¿no? En
vez de switch
o
a ver, al final es operativa, ¿no?
Porque sí que puedes te, o sea, no lo he
probado. Vale, pero espera que lo pongo
en HD. operativa es, pero si cortas el
cable de eh del cer
al menos para el PC3.
Vale, vale.
Por eso digo que no sabía cómo quitarlo
y estaba usando Switch. A ver,
no os lo digo porque a mí me pasó
y también lo a ver, creo que los he
puesto todos es por no por no
descargarme ese tuyo. Vale, este es que
claro, no quiero ponerlo para compartir
porque los demás compas están están
haciéndolo.
Entonces,
a ver, pruébalo, pruébalo. Quita el
switch ese y pon un y pon un hub
o puedo poner todo si quieres
también,
pero bueno, yo voy a voy a probarlo
quitarnos a Switch
y tú si quieres pues cambias todos los H
y.
A ver, bueno, sí, pero
es que no sé cómo la configuré el otro
día, que a mí no me no me aparecía esto,
o sea, estaba todo en verde y y sí que
usé switch, ¿eh?
Ahora la abriremos.
Mira, poniendo todo me salen dos en
rojo.
Te sale dos, pero dale tiempo, dale
tiempo que igual
no. O sea, en rojo y partido encima.
Sí, igual es la propia conexión de HCP.
También
sería probar a ver si en si no
poniéndolo en DHCP.
Yo es que creo recordar que a mí no me
salía el
no me salía esto.
A ver, porque si yo cojo
de aquí hasta aquí, o sea, realmente
funciona todo.
Error no da, no en ningún sitio.
Solo nos da error si cortamos el cable.
Sí, si cortamos, sí. Si no va bien.
Ahora abriré la que hice yo el otro día
porque yo creo recordar que no me que no
me aparecía nada de esto.
Y la de punto a punto nada, estaba nada
estaba bien sin problema,
hasta que cortamos el cable
con House. O sea, sí, con House también
me sale esto en rojo.
Te sale en rojo.
Me sale en un solo PC en rojo. En los
demás verde.
No entiendo.
Bueno, ahora lo vemos. Ahora lo vemos.
Hoy tenemos hasta las 8, ¿no?
Sí.
Y luego tenemos
sistemas. A ver si en sistemas
voy a entrar en sistemas. Ah, vale. Lo
que quería decir del
de aquí packet tracer. O sea, para que
no os pase, ¿vale?
Nosotros venimos aquí, vamos a
configurar esto, tools, no, perdón,
opción, opciones, preferencias.
Aquí en Misteránea le decimos
qué nos guarde
cada 5 minutos o cada minuto. O sea,
tampoco estamos haciendo proyectos muy
grandes. Entonces es interesante.
Imagínate que
tienes ahí hecho bastante de cara al
examen. Es interesante tener esto
activado
para que no os pasen
percances de estos.
Vale, lo que no sé exact, voy a ver
dónde te lo guarda.
A ver si tiene alguna ruta por ahí.
Mira, pues posiblemente sea este,
¿vale? El donde está
en la carpeta. Si estáis en Windows, en
la carpeta de usuario.
Ahí te lo
ahí te lo va a guardar.
Lo más seguro. Lo más seguro así.
Vale, pero importante,
hombre. 5 minutos está bien. Es que un
minuto igual
aquí el modo de proceder es cuando
inicias el
cuando inicias el archivo es nombre, o
sea, guardarlo aunque lo tengas vacío,
¿vale? Porque si no te lo más seguro es
que te lo te lo guarde con un nombre
extraño y a lo mejor no le lo digo por
cómo funcionan otros programas sin haber
probado la copia de seguridad de Packet
Tráer.
¿Vale? Entonces la lo que lo que
deberíais de hacer, lo que yo haría
sería me abro el archivo antes de de
empezar a a meter componentes, lo guardo
como el archivo que como lo quiero
llamar, ¿vale? Y ya sobre eso voy
haciendo voy guardando conforme voy
trabajando
y tienes el respaldo de la copia de
seguridad en un intervalo de 5 minutos o
de 1 minuto.
Un minuto puede ser excesivo, 5 minutos
pueden estar, no sé, o sea, eso
valoradlo vosotros
que luego te ha fallado, pues nada, te
vienes aquí a la a la carpeta de a la
carpeta de de Packet Tracer, donde se
supone que lo guarda y de ahí lo puedes
rescatar, que lo más seguro es que te lo
Mira, voy a voy a ver, voy a dejarlo un
minuto.
Aquí no se le dice aceptar ni nada, o
sea, lo cambias y ya está.
No tiene nada más.
Vale, entonces voy a guardarlo
guardo con prueba.
Al final miro el disco duro está lleno
de pruebas por todos los sitios.
Vale, este señal a prueba. Lo guarda
ahí. Cada minuto en teoría debería de de
ponerse a guardarlo.
Vale. ¿Cómo vais? Jorge ya lo ha
enviado. ¿Cómo vais los demás?
Se terminar ya. Vale,
le voy a abrir el mío a ver cómo está.
Ah.
Ya habr pasado un minuto. Usasco.
No.
Vale, perfecto.
Vale, veis, aquí, por ejemplo, me está
creando un un archivito cada minuto que
se llama prueba back. O sea, luego
simplemente, o sea, aquí lo normal es
que cojamos
este prueba back.
Vamos copiar. O sea, yo suelo tener este
tipo de de precauciones y luego nada,
simplemente le decimos PKT.
Vale, nos dice, "Al cambiar la extensión
de el archivo puede quedar
inutilizable." ¿Está seguro que desea
cambiarla? Sí.
Vale. Y ya sería, o sea, realmente sí
que le pones la extensión punto back
para que sepamos que es esa la la
copia de seguridad que nos está
haciendo.
¿Vale? Entonces lo abrimos y sí que nos
lo va nos lo va a abrir. A ver, no
tenemos nada, realmente no contenía
nada, pero veis. A ver, espera.
Aquí está abierto sin absolutamente
nada, pero
por eso interesante que os pongáis
preferencias, mielánea,
lo ponéis cada minuto, ¿vale?
y que cada minutos lo guarden.
Vale. Y ahora voy a abrir yo mi
archivito este de Topologs.
H
Yo creo que
A ver.
¿Has probado, Jorge, a quitarle
a quitarle algún cliente?
Eh, no,
pruébalo a ver.
Quitarle uno, no Solo.
Este
Mira, yo por ejemplo con todo Hubs
no me aparece la
no me aparece el el este el
A mí con todo hubs me sale eh una
connexion entre hub en rojo y luego un
hub y un PC en rojo. Pues eso es por
eso es por algo, pero no debería de O
sea, mira, realmente
y quitando un PC con los switches
tampoco se quita eso es
tampoco te lo te lo pone. Bueno,
¿cómo le has ido poniendo los cables?
¿De forma automática o cómo?
Eh, sí. Vale,
ahora te pasaré, os pasaré el archivo
ahora cuando
Vale, esta sería punto a punto. Vamos a
poner esta, me la cargo.
Ese de más de más de tres servidores.
Mal.
A ver.
Vale, ¿cómo vais? No, ya hemos agotado
ahí los tiempos.
Ya, yo no entró.
Venga, genial. Vale, gracias.
Argo. Hm.
Ah. Lo tienes que la Me voy a tener que
descargar la versión la versión nueve.
No, no lo puedo abrir, eh, Alex,
tengo la versión una versión anterior.
Ah, pues si quieres mañana
no te no me no me voy a instalar yo la
versión nueve. Me esté hace poco porque
como no tiene poquet hace poco. Pues
no te preocupes,
no te preocupes.
Vale,
de hecho, mira, me la voy a descargar
y lo instalo aquí también.
Como sí que creo que sí que te permite
tener varias.
Creo que sí.
Vale, la
versión nueve la tengo en el,
o sea, lo digo por si no os da fallo o
cualquier cosa en algún momento de la de
la película.
Yo la tengo en el en el Drive, ¿vale? os
la
os en el caso de que imagínate que nos
falla por lo que sea, ¿vale? Pues de ahí
la podemos sacar. Está comprimidas, son
los 280
megas comprimidos
y que ocupan 280 megas también,
o sea, no se ha comprimido nada, pero
simplemente es que está renombrado como
como zip.
Pues yo me la me la voy a descargar. La
voy a me voy a descargar de ahí del
Drive.
Vale. Jessica, ¿cómo vas con el con el
paquet tracer este? Con el ejercicio
voy más o menos. Voy casi terminándolo
ya. Sí, vale.
Me queda poco.
Vale, pues venga, lo me lo me lo
entregas, ¿vale? Cuando
Sí, sí,
enseguida.
Vale, Álvaro, me lo has enviado también.
Venga, genial.
A ver,
aquí está.
Vale, el tuyo sí que lo he podido abrir,
Álvaro. Bien,
está bien. Más o menos.
Sí. Estaba mirando el tema de las IPs y
eso. ¿Lo has puesto en No, no lo has
cambiado las IPs? No,
no los he puesto en el HCP, creo. Es que
se me estaba desconfigurando todo el
rato, entonces
lo he puesto de HCP y a tomar.
No has dejado una pipa, ¿no?
Sí,
todo. Vale, vale. Pero has no has creado
un servidor de HCP, ¿no? O sí,
no,
no.
Es que se me está desconfigurando todo
todo el rato, entonces no sé si está
bien o está mal.
Ya, claro. ¿Sabes por qué a esto te
refieres? No,
o sea, vale, realment
porque eso sí que lo he puesto
configurado, no he hecho.
Y es que esto si lo habrás hecho más de
una vez, seguro. Lo que pasa que de una
vez a otra se nos se nos va. Si a mí me
ha me ha pasado esto también. Vale. Eh,
para empezar aquí, o sea, aquí le añades
la IP.
Vale, sería una IP estática del
servidor. Pues yo que sé, las otras,
¿cuáles has hecho?
Ah, las otras no no si están en están en
DHCP, que digo yo. Vale, pues te vienes
192, yo que sé, 1 168 punto
pun 20.1, uno, por ejemplo.
Vale, entonces nos venimos aquí al de
HTP, o sea, esa el primer paso sí que
sería este, el crear la la dirección del
del servidor, la dirección IP de este de
esta de este equipo, que en este caso el
servidor. Luego lo siguiente,
vale, cerramos esto y nos Ah, vale, es
que era aquí, ¿vale? Nos venimos aquí al
al DHP,
¿vale? Y aquí sí que le decimos que
empieza a asignar las direcciones desde
el
con, perdón, con este seleccionado,
porque primero tenemos que seleccionar
este y aquí ves que se queda así en gris
porque si no lo seleccionamos. A ver
cómo
Bueno,
la verdad es que no hace no hace mucho
caso, pero bueno. O sea, lo hemos
seleccionado, lo tenemos seleccionado y
cada cada cambio que hagamos aquí, por
ejemplo, aquí que ponemos 20, pues que
empiece en la 20, por ejemplo, también y
que nos cree 512. no nos va a crear
nunca porque suc su
su eh su máscara de red no lo va a
permitir, pero lo ponemos que nos quede
15, por ejemplo, que es que tampoco
tampoco vamos a vale tú en el de cero y
le decimos guardar. Entonces ahora ves
que ya nos lo ha cambiado.
Aquí sí que nos lo está cambiando ya.
Luego la puerta de enlace, pues
ponemos la misma del
168.20,
que sería realmente la IP del equipo. O
bueno, podríamos ponerle el podríamos
iniciar con con uno, por ejemplo. Bueno,
el caso, a ver,
eh, servidor DNS, pues podría ser propio
servidor igual, no lo sé. O sea, esto ya
no no nos va a afectar mucho. Lo que sí
que nos va a afectar es
el tema de dónde queremos que nos
empiecen las las IPs y cuántas queremos.
¿Vale? Entonces, aquí ya estaría
emitiendo
y luego eso lo tenemos que poner en cada
en cada equipo, en cada cliente lo
ponemos lo tenemos que poner en modo
DHCP que ahí sí que lo habías puesto tú.
Vale, entonces, vale, en ese sentido
está está bien. Te ha faltado lo del lo
del servidor. A ver, si hubieras dejado
todo clientes en modo pipa, pues tampoco
hubiera pasado nada. O sea, aquí el tema
es que
lo ideal es hacerlo así, ¿vale? Porque
porque ya que estamos configurando algo
que por lo menos tenga un sentido.
Vale, vale.
O las pones todas. Ah,
me ha quedado claro.
Escucha, o las pones todas en modo
estático. Por ejemplo, si ves que te, a
ver, si ves que dices 15 minutos,
[__] no me da tiempo de ninguna
manera. Tal bla, tal. Lo haces en modo
¿Por qué? Pues porque no a ver si esto
lo repasas y lo haces varias veces al
final cuando te pongas a hacerlo en modo
rápido es que ni te enteras. y lo haces
s super rápido sin darte cuenta, pero si
no pues hzlo fácil, vete a lo vete a lo
fácil, ¿sabes? Para al final sabes
hacerlo, pero no te acuerdas exactamente
el procedimiento y ya está.
Vale, a ver, voy. Vale, genial, Jessica.
A ver, guardar. Y ahora, ahora sacaré el
el que hice yo el otro día, que
básicamente todos habéis hecho.
Bueno, voy a ver el día de Jessica
porque como Yasica no vio las topologías
que estuvimos haciendo estos otros días,
Vale, los has puesto en estática,
eh, en modo estático, ¿no? Las IPS.
Sí, lo he hecho así. Las IPs.
Vale, vale, vale. Y el router, por
ejemplo,
lo has puesto a ver la inter,
pero no le has asignado una red al
router.
Entonces, todos Claro,
que me No sé, es que me he empezado a
liar con lo del tema de mensaje de no sé
qué y digo, me estoy empezando a liar.
Se hace lo de la IP, pero lo otro no.
Vale, vale. A ver.
Como se lo has puesto fija,
sí.
Eh, a ver, 19. A ver, ¿en qué se lo has
puesto. Ah, ahora lo ahora lo paso por
ahí.
Vale.
1 2 1 6 8.
Vale, ir haciendo este. Mirad, os he Y
ahora vemos este de las de las
topologías.
Vale, os he abierto uno que se llama,
¿vale? Está en simulacro examen, primera
evaluación en la en la en la aplicación
en redes locales,
¿vale? Y dentro del apartado actividades
no evaluables de primera evaluación
tenéis uno que se llama,
no, perdonar, perdón, no está ahí,
estaba ahí, pero lo he cambiado por eso.
Vale, os vais más hacia abajo donde pone
simulacro es también primera evaluación.
Ahí tenéis uno se llama consolidación,
un ejercicio.
Vale, tenemos,
a ver,
en tenemos 10 minutillos, ¿vale? Para
hacerlo y luego vemos otro de
direcciones IP.
Vale, ir haciéndolo.
Tenemos hasta hasta las 18:42.
Vale, ¿cómo vale?
Yoa,
mira una cosa del del ejercicio has
mandado.
Mira, cuando estás
A ver.
Oh.
Vale, ya estaría.
Ahora te lo enviaré, os lo enviaré
corregido, ¿vale? Los que así en los que
si no os envío nada es que no
es que no no hay no hay problema con lo
que habéis enviado.
Vale. Y vamos a ver el tema del
Lo habéis lo habéis hecho el
el ejercicio este de consolidación.
Yo no lo he terminado.
Yo tampoco.
Vale,
yo todavía no lo he terminado.
Vale, pues eh
es que quería pasar al tema de IPs
también, claro. que volvería tiempo así
un poquito todo, eh, aunque sea,
o sea, da cuenta
que en el examen tenemos una hora
y hay que hacer varias cosas.
Vale, os voy a enseñar
lo que estuvimos haciendo,
los que lo que estuvimos haciendo el
otro día y os envío el archivo.
Bueno,
en cuanto al tema de topologías,
¿vale? Y a la hora de representarlas
también
entiendo que la de punto a punto es
fácil para todos. Todos lo habéis
enviado. Bueno, había que hacer
Bueno, todos no lo habéis enviado.
Vale, a ver, esto lo voy a cambiar,
¿eh?
Ya estaría
Vale, aquí tenéis diferentes
configuraciones, pero ahora voy a pasar
Vale,
y ahora esperar lo guardado
vale guardado
y os lo paso por aquí.
Este no os lo pasé el otro día, ¿no? El
que estuvimos haciendo en clase, no me
suena.
Topologías.
Creo que no hay nada más que hacia
abajo. A ver.
Vamos a repasarlas así un poquito y
ahora vemos lo que
vale ahí tenéis.
Eso sería el archivo.
Vale, ya tengo entrado.
¿Cómo?
Te he entregado el trabajo de antes.
Ah, vale, vale, vale.
Que lo ha subido a la plataforma. Sí, la
plataforma.
Ah, vale,
vale, genial. Mira, vamos a ver, vamos a
ver el tema. Este os lo he subido,
¿vale? Entonces, tenemos,
bueno, es lo que estuvimos haciendo el
otro día, topología de buso lineal,
¿vale? Fijaros que algunos habéis
enviado cuando tenemos
una unión entre dos entre dos
dispositivos que son iguales,
realmente ahí deberemos de utilizar un
cable cruzado,
¿vale? Que sería esto de aquí. Entonces,
por eso esa línea discontinua,
lo digo porque alguno habéis enviado eh
elementos que eran iguales conectados
con con cable no cruzado.
Vale, pues ahí tenéis todas las
configuraciones. Este realmente, a ver,
es un poco
que nos hemos venido arriba con el, o
sea, realmente, o sea, es que no tendría
sentido que en esta en este extremo de
la red estuviese un servidor enviando de
HCP, pero bueno, el caso es que
funciona,
o sea, lo más lógico sería que partiese
de él todas las conexiones que que
estuviese por aquí arriba conectado este
switch, por ejemplo.
Luego también esta si ponemos todo, o
sea, esto lo estuve probando, probarlo
vosotros y hacer configuraciones.
Eh, si tú pones todos estos en DHCP y
tienes las los suficientes
eh las suficientes direcciones para
asignar en este servidor, tú realmente
puedes conectar esta red con esta otra,
¿vale? Entonces tendrías una topología
mixta,
estaría en árbol y lineal.
Vale. O te lo puedes llevar también a
luego puedes conectarlo con esto
también, no sé. O sea, podéis hacer
múltiples
múltiples configuraciones,
¿vale? Y luego aquí tenemos en maya.
En maya por la por internet hay un
montón eh de de
configuraciones de redes maya. Yo he
elegido esta
y al parecer funciona y no da ningún
error. Y luego, mira, Jorge, ¿ves? Esta,
por ejemplo, lo que estábamos hablando,
esta tiene todos estos.
Esta sí que funciona, no tiene ningún
ningún elemento. ¿Qué diferencia había
con la que has enviado tú? Tú sí que has
puesto aquí un servidor,
pero yo he puesto donde está el servidor
un hub y luego ese hub conectado en
servidor aparte.
Vale, vale. Has has añadido un elemento
más ahí. Sí,
vale, vale, vale, vale,
vale. Deciros que este servidor
realmente solo viene con un, A ver, lo
pongo. Este servidor solo viene con una,
creo recordar, con un con un puerto de
Cernet.
Creo recordar, eh, que solo viene con
uno y luego el otro se lo tenemos que
añadir nosotros.
A ver, voy a poner uno por aquí.
Es suena que es así.
Sí, míralo. Viene con uno solo. La
manera de de añadir un fastnet.
Apagamos.
Nos venimos, yo creo que es [risas]
este, creo recordar que es este módulo
de fase eternet. Y entonces lo llevamos
hasta lo llevamos hasta ahí y soltamos.
y y volvemos a encender la máquina,
¿vale? Entonces ya podemos configurarlo
otra vez.
¿Vale? ¿Veis? Aquí ya tenemos un fase
internet y otro.
¿Vale? Entonces, este nos lo cargamos
y luego tenemos esta configuración que
me dirás tú si no es lineal, o sea, si
no es circular,
que sí que lo ves. Lo que pasa es solo
tiene tres elementos
y no las posibilidades de conexión
[risas] a más sitios, pero bueno, aquí
faltaría el punto a punto por razones
por razones obvias. O sea, es que es muy
sencillita esa, hombre, saberla que es
todo, casi todos la habéis enviado bien.
Vale, pues ahí tenéis el archivo este,
hombre, si lo encontráis algún error,
decídmelo. Por ejemplo, aquí, a ver cómo
lo aquí la impresora no, porque está
Vale, no
porque aquí no está configurado como
como de http porque tampoco tampoco
podríamos. Vale, vale. Pues hay que este
este sería el
sería el archivo, ¿vale?
tema de
Vale, lo de consolidación,
esto lo guardo. ¿Qué es lo que he
toqueteado yo por aquí?
Nada, o sea, simplemente he creado el he
creado el servidor y me lo he cargado.
Ya está, no tiene más.
Vale.
Vale. o eh respecto al ejercicio este
que estábamos que estábamos mirando,
vamos a ver,
tenemos el consolidación,
¿vale? ¿Cuáles son las principales
ventajas que que proporcionan las redes
de ordenadores?
Vale, ¿qué sería, por ejemplo,
eh podré compartir recursos?
Exacto. La compartición. Vale, perfecto.
Luego un tema económico también, mayor
eficiencia de reducción de costos, por
ejemplo,
comunicación y colaboración entre
usuarios
y un acceso centralizado a la
información.
Podríamos destacar eso.
En asianos apunte. Espera que voy a voy
a borrar.
Vale, luego diferencias entre un entre
un servicio y un protocolo.
Vale, lo habéis
esperado. Eh,
¿cuánto cuánto os habéis enviado el
ejercicio este de consolidación?
Tú, Ale, sí que lo has enviado, ¿verdad?
Sí, yo sí te enviado.
Vale, que lo estoy viendo ahora.
Vale, pues enviarlo ahí y yo que sé y
por lo menos le echamos le echamos un
ojo o bueno, ya vista la hora que que
es, pues lo dejamos para mañana,
¿vale? Ir haciéndolo.
Bueno, genial. Gracias, Alex, que lo has
lo has enviado y
a ver.
Ay, disculpa que es que lo he puesto ahí
en público.
Se ha abierto ahí,
que esto se abre donde quiere luego
las dos pantallas. Si tuviera tres más
lío todavía.
Vale, a ver. Hm. Está bien, eh, por lo
que estoy viendo, está está Mañana
cogemos y y nos pondremos con
con redes IPs,
¿vale? Y miraremos
un listado de redes veremos veremos que
si son públicas, privadas y son
reservadas también,
cuál es su su IP, su su máscara de red,
etcétera, etcétera.
¿Vale? Pondremos ahí una lista y la y la
y la descifraremos entre todos,
¿vale? Pues si queréis lo dejamos lo
dejamos hasta aquí. Tenéis estudiados el
tema de las
de las topologías y en en Paquet Tracer.
Mirar alternativas por internet también
que las hay y muchas. Hay un montón,
pero sobre todo que funcionen,
¿vale? O sea, que cuando lo entreguéis
en el examen, en el examen vais a tener
aproximadamente para hacer ese esa parte
del del examen unos 15 20 minutos.
Entonces, tenerlo muy bien estudiado
porque tampoco hay tantas topologías
y oye, si os piden dos topologías, pues
saber qué es lo que vas a usar y qué es
lo que no. tenerlo ahí, entrenar con
eso, entrenar con eso porque es es bast
una parte bastante importante de la nota
en el caso de que salga esa pregunta.
Bueno, venga, lo dejamos aquí, ¿vale?
Hasta mañana.
Venga, gracias.
Vale, vale. Corto el la grabación. M.